TO ASK HIM, BUT IT DOES APPEAR
THAT HE'S FEELING BETTER.
>> JUST TRY TO PUSH ON.
PUSH OUR GUYS AROUND AND TALK
[ BLEEP ], BUT WE CAN DO THAT,
TOO.
AND WE SHOW THEM WHEN WE COME
BACK HERE WE CAN PUSH GUYS
AROUND TOO AND TALK [ BLEEP ] AS
WELL.
WELL, IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
WE TALK BLEEP [ BLEEP ] AND PUS
AROUND.
NOW WE COME INTO YOUR HOME TO
WIN THIS GAME AGAIN.
>> WHEN I ASK WHAT WE GOT TO DO,
THAT'S GREAT.
>> I'M 32 YEARS OLD.
I NEVER TALK [ BLEEP ] LIKE THAT
IN MY LIFE.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO START NOW.
I'M JUST TOO OLD FOR THAT
[ BLEEP ].
>> I'M HERE FOR IT ALL.
YOU MADE MY NIGHT.
I'M HERE FOR ALL THIS.
I LOVE THIS, MAN.
>> DOES THAT QUALIFY AS POKING
THE BEAR OR NUDGING THE --
>> THE MAN SAID HE'S COMING TO
YOUR HOUSE AND GOING TO END YOUR
SEASON.
I LOVE THAT.
>> I WOULDN'T CALL IT POKING THE
BEAR.
SOME TEAMS HAVE THAT WE'RE
REALLY TOUGH ATTITUDE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU PUT IT TO THEM
THEY START WHINING AND
COMPLAINING.
NOW, WHEN YOU POKE THE BEAR,
MAKE SURE YOU PERFORM, MAKE SURE
YOU GET ALL THE REBOUNDS AND
MAKE SURE YOU PLAY.
LISTEN, WE'VE ALL TALKED TRASH
IN BASKETBALL.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T GET GOING
UNTIL THEY TALK.
DRAYMOND, K.G., THEY HAVE TO
TALK TO GET THEM GOING.
LISTEN, EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BE
WATCHING THAT GAME.
I'M JUST PROUD OF TREY BECAUSE
HE'S GROWN UP.
LAST COUPLE YEARS HE WAS A STEPH
CURRY WANNABE AND NOW HE'S
CONTROLLING THE GAME AND NOT
GETTING CAUGHT UP IN THE B.S.